you still uh doing the weird uh no
dating [ __ ]
no no no i've been doing a little bit of
dating man yeah
baby 2022 wife hunt oh
wife on you're into finding a wife like
for a wife are you oh wow thank you
but it also has to be i have to be able
to make it sexually sustainable i've
realized meaning huh meaning you have to
know okay i have to be able to have sex
for the next 40 years yeah you know yeah
but also at our age 40 you're being
generous yeah
yeah that's not that bad yeah i could do
that yeah you're thinking too much in
the long term yeah thanks i'm gonna re
redo that part well but just kind of
fall in love and then see where it goes
but if i'm with him if the physical is
not there yeah but but it's gonna be
there if you just [ __ ]
you're thinking too much dude just
[ __ ] meet someone and fall in love
with them dude feel overthinking if you
put us together it's the perfect amount
yeah bro theo's over here i'm over here
puts together you got magic and that's
how you came in yeah i guess so you need
me
i just kind of am like i think of things
the right amount of way and then [ __ ]
kind of just do it just be guys just how
about be people guys huh be people i'm
doing it
now you're kind of doing it yeah get
into more of the doing a person kind of
thing yeah yeah hey what's up
i don't know
that was actually very bobby lee of you
yeah that wasn't it um that didn't seem
natural
[Music]
and the sting and the wing
[Music]
you